das ist q& zu dirfolg ADH bei
Erwachsenen Anpassung bis zum Burnout
danke für te Geschichte für Kommentar
für mitfüh viele wiedererkennt der Rep
das freut mich natürlich mir auf die
wichtigste Frage und ich Psychiaterin
Ursula da da be mir im Q&A der forsch
über 40 Jahr zu ADHS und therapiert
betroffen schön s da die erste Frage ist
vom Nicola
a W wie ist der unch von ADS zu ADHS das
ist
vi der Unterschied ist das
ADHS Menschen die sind hyperaktiv werd
aggressiv nach
also
Hyperaktivität
ADSler die werdet hyperaktiv nach Inn
das heißt die denk studiert hab ganz
viele Schlaufe hirnet und man seht nach
relativ wenig und drum wird das hfig
auch gar nicht so gut entdeckt also
quasi zu Philip WSUS der ewige Zweifler
K sagen Kön wir sagen was sie B
gemeinsam Hand ist Hoh Sensibilität also
sie spüren Sache schnell und viel und
merk alles und dann die schnell
Reaktivität und der Adler der reagiert
nach H wir aggressiv und der AD der
studiert und studiert und studiert und
kommt dann zur Entscheidig je nach mit
Nico 55
41 mit RKI h
Diagnose ADHS
verwachs ADS ist aus me Sicht kein
krankit sondern ein genetisch bestimmter
neurotyp also das her B anders verdrotet
vernetzt etc und das wacht man natürlich
nicht aus aber was man mit dem Alter mit
dem Erwachsen Werder ist man lernt
besser mit se Persönlichkeitstyp UMG und
je besser man lernt damit Umzug um soo
weniger fallt dann auf und zu dem Umgang
gehört natürlich als erst dass man sich
akzeptiert also Akzeptanz gegenüber für
sieine Eigenschaften neigige und
figkeiten natürlich auch kan vielleicht
zum n Kommentar überleen vom
Tom se viel Dank für Reportage wichtiges
Thema aber Allgemeinheit weiß Zen drüber
akzeptiert sie vi Zen wie wie s wir da
der Gesellschaft und Kommentar der
forsch wie wie St da
ADH also ich habe mich schon über mit
befasst ich hab dann ad und ad ich weiß
nicht genau ob gen wirklich
unterschiedlich ist oder ob sich das nur
bildet dur Interaktion mit dem
Umfall in der Gesellschaft jetzt in
letzter Zeit ist Ries Hype und alle red
drüber und alle sind fachl drüber und
sogar fachl D das ist nur modrank also
wir bakatellisiert wir bakatellisiert es
ist überhaupt ke modekrankit dann gen
also genetische vererbig ist nie modrank
das isto
aber es macht der Hype mit
ADHS
was einer bewirkt dass ADS besser
akzeptiert wird so redet drüber
andersits bringt mit sich dass es all
alles bakatellisiert und banalisiert
wird und dass man dann wirklich
fachmeinige n gehört dann jeder ist
schon Experte und viele sag da der hat
das stimmt auch nicht es ist nicht Eis
gehen wo das wier geht sind von 30 bis
100 oder vielleicht sogar mehr ist
sogenannt Genom das heißt also mischig
von Gen wo innerhalb von Familie
wier gut Stichwort jeder h der Jonas
Meer
seid h nicht nur 5% sondern vielleicht
95% ADH interessant wäre wie sich den
aDHS bei Menschen äußert die irgendwo
fern ab Zivilisation geboren wurden und
dort leben also quasi Kel V Gaming
Streaming Social Media was hät es
fürluss
also die digitale Welt hat sicher ein
influss aber sie produziert K ad he sie
produziert höchstens vollgekrank das
heißt Abhängigkeit von der digitale Welt
süchtigkeit von der digitale Welt dann D
ist alles klar reguliert das kann lernen
man muss nicht auf emotionale Sache
reagieren und von S ich dann verblöde
einfacht wir simpel aber es löst
nicht sondern nur richtig zu der
Diagnose das sehr fest beschäftiget vi
wiedkennt Frage sich jetzt nach der Rep
h ADH muss ich mich abkl
z genau wegen einer solchen Reportage
kam ich darauf dass ich DHS haben könnte
und auch in dieser Reportage es werden
meine Probleme im Alltag beschrieben von
den Betroffenen oder der lilag tol tolle
Reportage da danke ich wieder ach ich
mir auch abklären ja wenn s
abklären hez Tag D sich vi selber
diagnostizieren über so Reportage über
Sache wo sie SST auf Youtube oder wo
immer im Internet LT ich sag nein man
muss sich nicht unbedingt abklären es
geht er wo sagt man muss unbedingt
abklären diagnosemer an der stelle ich
sag nein stimmt überhaupt nicht alsober
Diagnose ja ja
DFF und ich würde nicht abklär ich würde
z ADS Spezialist also wo sich aus mit
ADS Menschen und dann würde ich mich
gerade Berat ich w gar nicht machen also
wen
ge aufgrund von Internetrecherche denn
gerade in ADH Berat
ja ich würde gerade Z erfahrene
Person wo weiß wie man UMG mit rotleck
geh berot Begleit aber abklär braucht
nicht die braucht nur wenn man für
irgendees Dokument also z.B für das Kind
damit Extras bezahlt wird und das auch
unterschiedlich dann mus vielleicht so
vorwesen der braucht ja eigentlich
Psychiater gar nicht wenn man gar nicht
Fachperson braucht für so es gibt nicht
so viele Berat WG mits und ich bin
psychiatrin ich habe viel Erfahrung mit
AD ich ber vi aber ich l nicht no extra
abklären ich k sie auch nicht selber mit
dem neuropsychologischen Test ab das
wird hezutag so gemacht ich nehme
einfach D Generationen
Anamnese Familie v aber Diagnose h
überkt hilft es vi Diagnose
zu je nachdem also wenn man als
erwachsen sagen wir jetzt mit 30 40 dann
die Diagnose überkommt da sag vi das AH
Erlebnis jetzt verstand ich m auf ich
hab leten vortragt da 0jährige Frau G
und die hat gesagt jetzt FT wie Schuppe
vor den Auge jetzt verstand ich mich
endlich und für das ist hil für das ist
wenn man be der Kinder schon sehr früher
macht für Kinder wä es nicht notwendig
für Lehrer vielleicht damit ihr das
akzeptiert und vielleicht dann auch
rüsicht oder lern mit de Kinder um sch
wi gerade gut die brückbildig System h
Kommentar g TR V der schuhinger Frage
das schriebt der Alchemilla ich erlebe
mein ADH als Fluch und als Segen
zugleich wenn in unserem in unseren
Bildung sein Richtungen
potenzialorientiert gelehrt würde hätten
alle was davon also was ist Strof V
Schuh da hab ich eine große Kritik der
Schul Schul hingt recht hin der D und
zum Teil geht Lehrer wo sehr begabt sind
wo könt mit de Kinder UMG und zum Teil
überhaupt nicht und in der Schu wird oft
noch mit belohnig und bestroph geschafft
funktioniert überhaupt nicht be ADS
Kinder
er seid das richtig man müss die
Ressource oder Potenzial orientiert die
verschiedene Kinder unterstütz in dem wo
sie gut sind und nicht dem bestrafen wo
sie schlecht sind und wenn sie bisschen
gut sind kann man auch die andere fcher
wo nicht so gut sind kann man die nach
de mitol aber Schulsystem ist noch
längstens nicht auf ADS und ADS
ausgichtet le sie die wichtig Z
zegsperster das Frage Thema hing und
ADHS da steht vom emotionals ich finde
Familiengründung Kinder zu haben und ADS
aDHS ist eine enorme Herausforderung
auch weil die Freiheit stark eingegrenzt
wird und die organisatorischen
Herausforderungen zunehmen wie la das
beratig therapieutag also sicher D ad
Kinder ältere stärker Herausforder es
ist stärkere Herausforder und drum sage
ich wenn
elterchlag oder Liebe schon vor Set Sie
unbedingt sich hilf aber halt nicht man
h konkret die familietig Stelle Elter
bertig Stelle B therapeute natürlich
aber es m immer therapeute sie wo W wir
mit und es geht nicht so viele leider
das Hund jetzt erst
langsam gut nachher aber auch ADHS
Person wo ihres Umfeld pragt da fragt
der kuris also du schn Kürze danke für
Reportage 5 Jahre mit der ADHS
Betroffene intensiv zammen geschaffen
ist völlig Limit es h in krank gemacht
sie hat keine
Reflexion h das ADH völlig ausgbt und
hte schendlich Job kündet also wie fest
mit dem AD UMF mal scharf belaste kan
das ist durchus möglich und da G
wiederum Regler also ich ber natürlich
vi wo eine AD ist od oder eine AD und
eine AD und da der Partner dann wieder
unterstütz dass er lernt mit der
Situation UMG und vielleicht wichtigste
ist dass man nicht verantworttig für
Emotionen v übernimmt wenn der
hochemotional ist dass man lernt umz mit
den intensive Emotionen ohne immer
gerade sich schuldig fühle und dass man
in Ruhe probiert Sache auseinander ne
und das mache ich natürlich mit also
viele Elter hab ADS W Kinder ADS hab und
dann gehört Paartherapie gehört zur
berotik vom Kind und Kind ghen ich dann
oft gar nicht sondern neltere und mE
aber ja eine von der tere h ja auch auf
nach
Medikament Strategie schon Thema bei der
Community das z. der R Malin heißt
Cannabis ich extrem gemerkt dass die
Pflanze me beruhigt und and frag ja wie
überkt man medizinisch Cannabis das der
bewaltigung iMag mit
ADH ich nar auch wieder über 40 Jahr
lang sucht Strategie gemacht bevorst von
me sucht Therapie Cannabis hat viele
verschiedene Substanzen und hat
beruhende wke das stimmt und drum
verwendet viele zum schlafen aber
Cannabis dort gichzeitig auch die ganze
vernetzig im her verarbeitet
vit verschlechter also verdum blödet
verblödet und ich ganz allgemein alle
suchubstanz D lern verhinderen und die D
Cannabis konsumiert alles so gich aber
ist schon nicht Idee dass ein alles gich
ist sondern es ist wichtig dass man aus
jeder schwierige Situation lernt und das
lern das wird wegen ja
sowieso sucht und ADHS h ja
ofhang es geht viel
mehr suchtr unter der AD he dannn sie
verwendet Zuchtmittel zum ihre
Impulsivität hol aber es ist keine gute
Methode n seit Isabel K se der Wunsch
ich hat ich hätte es schön gefunden wenn
ihr noch jemanden interviewt hättet der
koneritalin nimmt nach diesem Dock ist
dies für mich ein bisschen negativ
dargestellt worden ich hat tsä nur
Protagonist im Moment ke Medikament
inklusive mir do probiert mit dem
franois
Therapeut zeig des
Ritalin sehr
gut aber vi hier z ganzig
wenn
Medik it so wenn nicht
vi ja also
verwamphetamin
also
geht
vielezutag die H natürlich sehr stark B
der fokussieren und in der Schule sind
Kinder zwungen fokussieren und von Kön
dann oft Note um ein Punkt oder meh u
wenn drun studiert kann man wieder gut
braen früh hab erzt sogar das einfach
genau sie Zugang für PRF
Ritalin genau ja V her hilft sicher be
der intellektuelle leichtig es hilft ab
beim stür erklär der stürerklärusf und
so langwillige Sache dann macht man es
wo schadet also alle wo künstleris tätig
sind heißt ja
Aufmerksamkeitsstörung und ich sag
breite Aufmerksamkeit also dieesh alles
l alles an gut
granz und V natürlich kreativ Tätigkeit
hilft nicht sondern macht
stumpfer
ma und dem sind sag dass
sie weniger kreativ sind zum Thema
ritalinmbruch hat no schfm gemacht zu d
es GI Z steigero gar nicht ADH verlinken
euch Frau da 40 über 40 Jahr erfahr mit
AD g N ich wirk auf der Zunge BRT sag
das muss man no W oder sagen was mehr
als Medizinerin und Psychiaterin auf der
Zunge brennt ist das man bei All
untersuchiger und behandl immer nur das
medizinische Modell verwendet wo man nur
auf der Patient fokussiert und da um
macht also mit Medikament verhaltensapie
und soer und Umfall wo ja interagiert
mit den Menschen mit den Kinder das wird
überhaupt Weg wird nicht ber und Kön
unglaublich viel Geld sparen wenn Umfeld
früher berot wird soass ad Kinder ke
krank werden also aber die tere Berat
jawoh jawoh jaw danke viel
mal fürusfü für die Expertise sehr
spannend und ich danke viel mal für
Interesse
tschüssammen